- [Announcer] This UCSD-TV program is
presented by University of California
Television. Like what you learn? Visit our
website or follow us on Facebook and
Twitter to keep up with the latest
programs.
♪ [music] ♪
- [Narrator] We are the paradoxical ape.
Bipedal, naked, large-brained. Long the
master of fire, tools and language, but
still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable, yet filled
with optimism. We grow up slowly. We hand
down knowledge. We empathize and deceive.
We shape the future from our shared
understanding of the past. CARTA brings
together experts from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights on who we are and how
we got here, an exploration made possible
by the generosity of humans like you.
♪ [music] ♪
- [Philip] Please, as we wrap up, don't
forget to write down your questions and
pass them down to the points where they
can be collected so that we can progress
pretty quickly at this point to the
question-answer period. I've been asked to
try to wrap this up, which I suppose means
provide a summary and an appraisal of
what's been said. This is certainly not an
easy task given all of the information and
interpretations. We've had a lot of very
interesting presentations during the
afternoon. I certainly can't hope to do
justice to all of this material. Let me
just run down the list quickly for you.
Bernard Wood and Bill Kimbel spoke to the
difficulties associated with recognizing
and studying the genus homo, and I agree
of course, we all realize that the record
is imperfect. Bill Kimbel also filled us
in the important new discoveries from Ledi
Geraru in Ethiopia. Earliest homo now, a
small mandible at 2.8 million years.
That's very fine material to have.
Dan Lieberman spoke about hunting and
gathering as facilitated by double B&B,
brawn and brains and of course the
interactions between those two. I did the
best I could to tell you a little bit
about the fascinating discoveries from
Dmanisi, first humans out of Africa into
Asia. Pascal Gagneux gave us a little
shift of gears which was very fine indeed.
He spoke about the sialic acids and the
possibility that an immune mechanism could
have driven speciation in homo between two
and three million years ago. Steve
Churchill spoke to endemism, the
importance of endemism in southern Africa.
And he spoke again about olive baboons as
a possible model for Homo erectus. Carol
Ward, again, spoke to deficiencies in the
fossil record. There aren't very many
postcranial remains for earlier homo.
That's the case, we do the best we
can...or she does the best she can. Leslie
Aiello gave us her latest synthetic
thinking on life history patterns and
Hominins, spoke to the importance,
probably, of cooperative behavior.
Certainly I agree. Herman Pontzer spoke
again about energy as Dan Lieberman had
done earlier. A little bit of point and
counter-point. Herman spoke about the
Hadza project. The Hadza turned out not to
be so energy-expensive after all. Herman
also spoke to the benefits of fat, which
is a fine thing.
Let me end, I don't want to wrap up at any
great length, but let me end on an
optimistic note. Yes, the fossil record is
imperfect and we've all known that for a
long time, but it is getting better. We
do, in fact, have a huge amount of
information. There are literally hundreds
of Hominin fossils in the record and we
now have some very sophisticated
techniques that we can use to study them.
This is progress. Our understanding of
human or Hominin evolution as it is now in
2016 is very different from what was
thought about the Hominins 50 years ago.
We are making progress. Leslie Aiello said
that she was pleased she wasn't born a
Neanderthal, I suppose we all are, but at
the same time we now know that we all
share genes with the Neanderthals. Two or
3% at least. We didn't know that 10 years
ago. So you see? Things are not so bad
after all.
- [Steven] Okay, well we've now reached
the question and answer period, and I'm
madly sorting through questions down here.
I've got some questions directed at the
speakers in the first half of the
symposium and I'll call you each down and
grill you with the questions one-by-one.
So why don't we begin with Pascal? If you
would come up. I saw a few good ones in
here for you. Okay. First question reads,
"Do you have any idea what the pathogen
could be that was driving the sialic acid
shift, the sexual selection... ?" It's a
two-parter, you want them one at a time or
you want me to hit you with both of them?
Okay, you can take them both? All right.
Number two, “Is it possible to retrieve
glycol molecules from fossils that are
greater than two to three million years
old?”
- [Pascal] Great question. Which pathogen
might have driven the change in sialic
acid? I mentioned one possibility:
malaria. Another very intriguing
possibility is actually pathogens from the
many species of prey animals that were
being slaughtered. If you slaughter an
animal bare-handed with stone tools,
you're likely to have a lot of scratches
and cut yourself. So I don't have a good
candidate, but there is no shortage of
pathogens known to bind sialic acid.
Tellingly, the ones that bind pig sialic
acids don't bind human sialic acids.
E.coli, there's a famous E.coli that makes
pigs very sick, it cannot infect us
because it's not looking for the sialic
acid we have. So I think the slaughtering
and hunting connection, as a top predator,
your pathogen regime really changes,
especially when you start transporting
meat. The second question was can you
retrieve a sialic or bits thereof in
fossils. The good news is yes, actually
Ajit and his team looked at the
Neanderthal type specimen powder left over
after DNA extraction, and found that just
like humans, it also had only the AC, the
new 5AC sialic acids. Ann Bergfeld, who
went back to Germany, a former post-doc in
the Varki lab, has been able to find
traces of sialic acid in bones from east
Africa provided by Meave Leakey that are
three million years old. So we hope that
we might actually get at fossil sialic
acid, which are the size of...maller than
one base of DNA. You don't need the long
chain.
- You're not off the hook yet. One more
question for you. “Roughly 15% of
infertile couples have an unknown cause.
First, could female testing of male sperm
account for part of this? And two, could
tests be developed to diagnose?”
- So that's an interesting idea looking
forward, or to the present. We have
actually just found evidence for the
presence of that antigenic sialic acid on
sperm of only fertility patients, not
normal fertile men. And we find the
presence of antibodies against it in the
fluid washed from the endometrium of women
undergoing fertility treatment. So there
is the distinct possibility of a very
delayed liability of abolishing part of
what used to be self that is now seen as
non-self.
- I have no further questions for the
defendant. So Bernard Wood, we'll call you
up. “Does using the concept of adaptive
grade as a means of recognizing genera
increase the taxonomic problems caused by
homoplasies? For example, the genus
paranthropus may be polyphyletic.”
- [Bernard] Yes and I agree.
- That's the only question I had for you,
so... Dr. Lieberman, come on down. So one
person asked, "How much does culture
affect anatomy? For example, texting with
thumbs. Does that increase that
representation in the brain?"
- [Daniel] Aye aye aye. It's an
interesting question, actually, because
there's two kinds of evolution that's
going on. There's evolution by natural
selection, sort of biological evolution
that we think about all the time. But
cultural evolution is also a very
important kind of evolution. And over the
last, I would say, 20 or 30 years there's
been an increasing appreciation about the
interactions between cultural evolution
and biological evolution. So a good
example might be that as humans starting
moving into temperate zones, right, we
started having to deal with colder nights
and we evolved the ability to make fire
and clothing. But that in turn permitted
selection to act on other aspects of our
phenotype. For example, maybe skin color
that could then respond to those
environmental challenges. So there's a
strong, important interaction between
culture and biological evolution. There
are no simple rules about them, but
they're important. Now whether or not
texting is gonna cause your thumbs to
change, that would only be the case if A
there was an inheritable variation in how
you texted that not only maybe improved
your performance, in terms of texting, but
also affected your reproductive success.
And my guess is...for example, yesterday I
was going to class, actually, I was
rushing to get to class and there was some
undergraduate who was texting while
walking on the stairs. And I suspect he
might've been lowering his chances of
surviving and reproducing. So you might
argue that if there's a genetic proclivity
to want to text in the first place, it
might lower your reproductive success. But
then again, there's Tinder and all those
other things, so I don't know.
- Hold on, more questions for you, Dan.
“Do you consider food processing to be
cooking?” So like I take it that chopping
and grinding, you were talking about. And,
“When did cooking with fire begin?”
- Good question. Okay, so I would say that
cooking is a form of food processing. So
there's mechanical food processing and
thermal food processing and chemical food
processing. So it is one of several
important forms of food processing. The
evidences to when cooking became
important...well let's just say it's a hot
topic. It's a hugely debated... The oldest
evidence that I know of that archeologists
accept for fire, that is we accept as
being sort of human-made, that couldn't be
brush fire is about one million years old,
from Wonderwerk Cave in southern Africa.
There are some older possible sites and
they're debated. But it's not really until
about 400,000 years ago, actually with
sort of archaic homo, homo
heidelbergensis, whatever you want to call
it, that we being to see regular evidence
of cooking. So the question really is, is
absence of evidence, evidence of absence?
And there's sort of a big debate about
that. I tend to think that...there's been
a lot of effort to find early cooking in
the archeological record, and I suspect
that the absence of evidence really is
evidence for absence, but that's highly
debated. But that said, there's no
question that when cooking became
important, it had a major, again, another
evidence of cultural-biological
interaction, it had really major effects
on our biology and transformed our biology
in all kinds of ways. And I highly
recommend that you read Richard Wrangham's
book “Catching Fire” if you want a nice
account of that. So cooking is important.
When it evolved? If you ask 10 people,
you'll get, I don't know, 10 answers.
- “If homo originated about 3.3 million
years ago, why do you think that fossil
evidence of homo would be nonexistent
compared to Australopithecus from the same
time?”
- [William] I don't necessarily think
that's true. And I also think they'll be
very hard to recognize at that time. One
of the things we understand since Darwin
is that species very close to branching
points should be expected to look a lot
more like each other than they look like
their respective descendants. So the
further you go back in time we go to a
root, the more difficult it is going to be
to distinguish the species on diverging
branches. But I am happy to be prepared to
accept Australopithecus as a stone tool
maker if that's what the evidence is going
to suggest. And let's not forget that
brain size increase did not start with
homo. The mean brain size for
Australopithecus is fully 30% bigger than
a chimpanzee's, and that is not a small
amount. So something is going on that's
driving brain size earlier than what we
think in the genus homo. Whether that is
tied to culture, I haven't a clue, and
that is obviously an area for
investigation.
- “Some argue for the placement of homo
rudolfensis and Homo habilis in the genus
Australopithecus.” I'm looking at you,
Bernard. What would you say to them?
- Well I'll tell you. Since you asked. You
see this title up here? It says Origins of
the Genus Homo. A genus is a taxonomic
category. Homo is a taxon. Let's say that
we follow the prescription that
Australopithecus, I'm sorry that homo
habilis and homo rudolfensis are primitive
enough in their adaptive suite that
they're much closer to some
Australopithecus ancestor than they are to
homo sapiens. And we take them out of the
genus homo for that reason. We could put
them in Australopithecus, we could come up
with another genus, it doesn't matter. The
problem is is that doing that exercise
does not actually move them off the tree
branch that leads to us. That is a
separate question relating to monophyly.
And we can move the taxonomic boundary
between the genus homo and the genus
Australopithecus until the cows come home,
but until and unless we have solid
evidence that they do not belong at the
root of the lineage, we actually haven't
addressed the interesting question, which
is the origin of a lineage, not of a
taxon.
- Dr. Rightmire. “If all the specimens
from the Dmanisi site are classified as
the same species, how can we explain the
great variation in them? What are the
implications that these specimens are
classified as one? Should we reconsider
the existing taxonomy within the genus
homo?”
- Well indeed, one of the big questions at
Dmanisi has been since we had Skull 5 come
out, one of the last items in 2005, how
indeed there could be such a lot of
variation within the assemblage, as we
refer to it, from Dmanisi. We did not
start with the assumption that just one
species is represented. We tried to reach
that conclusion by working through a lot
of material. We did resampling analysis
which I don't really want to talk about at
this point. There are a number of them and
they all point to the same conclusion. The
variability or variation within the
Dmanisi sample as nearly as we can assess
it from the body part in question: teeth,
mandibles, cranial form and so on, that
variation is about comparable at Dmanisi
to what you'd find in some of the most
dimorphic of the large apes. Gorillas, for
example. So I would say on that basis we
can't rule out Dmanisi as a single
population. A population belonging to a
single taxon. As far as the systematics of
homo are concerned, of course there are a
lot of questions. Everything should be
reassessed from time to time.
- One more for you. “The fossils from
Dmanisi seem, in many respects, more
primitive than African Homo erectus. Is it
possible that Homo erectus evolved outside
of Africa and moved back in later?”
- Good question. Yes indeed, it is
possible. We don't understand exactly how
all of this came down. We know that Homo
habilis is in the record in Africa and
Africa only. We know that Homo erectus is
in East Africa, certainly by 1.65 million
years ago. The best examples of African
Homo erectus, the more complete specimens
are about that age or perhaps a bit later
in time. There are some bits and pieces.
There is the backend of an occiput, for
instance, which is probably earlier,
although it's from a lag deposit. One
can't be certain that the date applied to
it is 100%. Dmanisi comes into the record
in West Asia at about 1.85, not human
material as I said, but stone tools
certainly indicating the presence of a
human population. Just what happened after
Homo habilis appeared and evolved and Homo
erectus flowered, both in Africa for a
time and certainly later in the Far East
is uncertain. I can't claim to know at
this point whether there was an anagenetic
evolutionary process going on in Africa, I
think it's likely: Homo habilis to Homo
erectus. Homo erectus then a primitive
form of Homo erectus at any rate.
The first Hominins out of Africa, we see
them at Dmanisi at 1.5 million years. The
other possibility is that it was an
earlier version of homo that left Africa
probably before 1.8, 1.9 million years ago
for which we have no evidence whatsoever.
Hominins evolved further in western Asia
and homo erectus as an Asian species then
moved back to east Africa, for example, as
we see it in the Turkana Basin. And indeed
African Homo erectus is more derived, or
more like Homo erectus than are the
Dmanisi Hominins. We have a couple of
questions for you. The first one is,
“Overall are humans getting larger?”
- Overall are humans getting larger? That
is an interesting question. First off, as
I think was alluded to, I forget where,
perhaps in Dan Lieberman's talk or Herman
Pontzer's talk, we need to be careful to
sort of distinguish between what we might
call our lean body mass versus our fat
body mass because we are very, very good
at putting on fat and we live in a very
calorie-rich environment where, you know,
off the dollar menu at McDonald's you can
buy more calories than most hunters and
gatherers are able to capture in a day. So
we're definitely getting larger in the
sense of our fat body mass is increasing,
but I think the record suggests that
humans kind of hit their apogee in the
middle Pleistocene. Because we have
individuals from places like the Sima de
los Huesos in Spain, there's an individual
there who looks like had a relatively lean
body mass of about 93.
And here I'm not talking about fat-free
body mass, I'm talking about sort of like
hunter-gatherer natural body mass,
probably about 93 kilos. There's a middle
Pleistocene individual from [inaudible
00:24:36] in Spain which also is about
that: 91, 93 kilos. And these individuals
are not necessarily super tall, they're
just relatively wide and stocky, and to me
that's kind of the apex of human body
mass, or size, and we've been going down
since then.
- You spoke to olive baboons as a possible
example for early homo. Why is that?
- Well again there is a suggestions on the
basis of the genetic evidence that they're
a hybrid species. I'm not necessarily
saying that Homo erectus evolved in a
hybrid zone between two species, but there
is a suggestion that what happens when
closely related taxa hybridize is that
sometimes structures get smaller in the
hybrid offspring, the F1 generation. In
other cases, structures get larger. In
some cases there are examples of hybrid
vigor, in other cases the hybrids do worse
than the pure strains of the two parent
species. So it's very hard to know what
can happen in cases of hybridization, but
it looks like in the olive baboons that
they were particularly successful and that
they'd been expanding their range and
they'd been swallowing up variation in
smaller populations of baboons that they
encountered. And I just think to me it's
interesting that it gets very, very
difficult to really nail down who the
ancestor of Homo erectus is.
I think in some regards, homo habilis
makes a great candidate ancestor, but
there are these other morphological groups
out there which share features with homo
erectus that homo habilis doesn't. And so
I just think it's worth it to sort of say,
"Hey, what if we're looking at an olive
baboon-type situation with Homo erectus?"
- Okay, thank you. Carol Ward, there are
some questions for you.
- [Carol] Can I just hijack things for
moment to address the body size question
again? What's really cool actually, a
million and a half years ago in some of
the [inaudible 00:26:54] isolated
postcranials and actually on the west side
of Lake Turkana too, we have a few bones
of individuals that were at least, if you
compare them to modern people for example,
maybe 6'3” or so, there's a hand bone,
there's a radius, there's distal humeri.
There were some really, really, really big
people...weirdly big, bigger than most
people are today, a million and a half
years ago. I don't know why. They seem to
be homo, I don't know why they got
smaller, why they were so big then, but
there's weird variation of body size
throughout the fossil record, but now I
can listen to the questions I'm supposed
to answer.
- Okay. “When did childbirth mechanics
change from presumably a chimp-like
situation to a modern human-like situation
necessitating fetal rotation? Head
rotation?”
- That's a great question, so the question
is when do the mechanics of childbirth
change? When you look at great apes, great
apes have big pelvic inlets, so the bony
hole in the middle of the pelvis is really
large, the babies are fairly small, and in
terms of getting the baby through, that's
not very difficult. When you get to
Australopithecus, the pelvis is, in
comparison, very short and it's also very
broad so the idea is the baby has a
tighter fit, but since the pelvis is
broad, the baby's head fits sideways, it
fits sideways all the way and there's
non-rotational birth.
When you get to modern humans, what you
see is there's a change in the birth canal
from the top of the pelvic inlet to the
pelvic outlet. And the baby's head
actually rotates so the baby comes out
facing away from the mother, usually, in a
normal birth process. And that seems to
have happened partly sometime with the
increase in brain size. From something
like an Australopithecus up to something
like a modern human, that you would change
the pelvic shape and you would change
rotational birth. So when, in the fossil
record, do you see something like that?
Well you would need a pelvis to see birth
canal size. We have australopith pelvises
which seem to be very wide, they all seem
to follow sort of a theme. We don't really
see in many fossil pelvises until we get
to something fairly recent. For example,
in China, except for one, which is maybe
0.9 to about 1.4 million years old from
Ethiopia from Ghana, it's probably homo
erectus although it's unassociated with
anything, and we don't know what a boisei
pelvis looks like, so...caveat. But it has
a very wide birth canal. Also has a very
large anterior posteriorly expanded, front
to back birth canal. So the whole thing is
big, both from the top and the bottom, and
so that individual wouldn't have had that
sideways non-rotational birth we see in
Australopithecus, so maybe about that
time? It's a little bit hard to say. The
other way that paleoanthropologists infer
things about the birth process is to just
say, "If you're getting a really big brain
and babies are born with a big brain,
that's gonna naturally take up more space
in the birth canal." So as we see brain
size increase, we saw that graph over and
over again where you get an exponential
rate of brain size increase, that's gonna
affect the birth process as well.
So you have probably multiple factors
changing. There've been energetic
arguments that affect timing and size of
babies during birth, all of those things
seem to happen sometime during the genus
homo, probably not at the origin of it
nearly as much as sometime during that
process, after the origin of the genus
homo leading up to the time we have larger
brains.
- One question is, “If sexual isolation
takes about five million years, how could
growth rates of species vary so quickly?”
- So yeah, again I don't really understand
what the question is asking. My comment
that it takes about five million years on
average for a large bodied mammalian
species to really become reproductively
isolated, that was based on work that
Trent Holiday did where he looked at pairs
of closely-related mammals where we had
either generally good genetic divergent
states, and he looked whether they were
truly infertile, if they followed
Haldane's rule where one sex was
infertile, or if they were fully
inter-fertile. And what he found is there
was a good amount of variations because
I'm sure that there are molecular things
that happen like the sialic acid, did I
get that right? No I didn't, anyway. But
on average it takes about five million
years. So how could growth rates of
species vary so quickly? That one, I would
basically say that it is probably a trait
which is controlled by many, many genes.
And when you have traits that have many
genes, you've got a lot of underlying
variation. Things like stature, going back
to body weight again, and body size are
also probably controlled by very many
genes, and so those traits actually are
very evolutionarily malleable and I would
suspect that's going on with growth rates,
although you would probably know better
than I do.
- [Leslie] Just following on from that,
the question about are we getting bigger
or smaller. It's all of the above. Because
your growth process depends on a number of
factors as I was talking about in my talk.
So depending on the energy coming into the
system, you're going to grow more rapidly
or not. And growing up in California here
in the 1950s, we used to call it the
orange juice effect, and I'm three inches
taller than any other woman in my family.
And that's a very good sign of how you can
modify the size of populations. And there
is very good evidence that during the
agricultural revolution, there was quite a
crash in body size because the low quality
of the diet they were eating. Okay, I have
a second question and it says, "Is it fair
to say that primitive man had childlike
cognition? How would you describe the
cognitive process of the genus homo?" Now
what this immediately made me think of was
Allen Walker who used to say "If you
stared into the eyes of the Turkana boy,
would you see a human staring at you or an
animal?" And that's a question we really
can't answer. And in terms of childlike
cognition, we're talking about different
species. Probably a good comparison is
your dog and how would you describe the
cognition of your dog who can be
tremendously smart in some areas and very
stupid in other areas? And the answer to
this question is we really don't know, but
it's probably more on the animal side
particularly when we're talking about the
origin of the genus homo.
But I always used to tell my students:
Whatever erectus was doing, they were
doing it right because they lasted for
over a million years and they spread
throughout the old world. So if that's
smarts, they were very smart.
- First question: “Can humans lower their
metabolic costs by reducing brain
activity? Less worrying, being more
meditative.”
- [Herman] My students try that every day.
No, actually, there's not a lot of great
data on the energy costs of the brain at
different activity levels, so thinking
versus not, but as far as we can tell, the
brain ia burning the same number of
calories whether you are intently figuring
out a math problem or playing chess or if
you're meditating. And that's actually
because most of what your brain does is
stuff that you're not aware of. They say
you only use 10% of your brain, but that's
absurd, you're using all of your brain all
the time for all the different things that
your body's doing and managing. So just
because you turn off, or it seems like you
turn off the conscious part of your brain
or turn that down, probably has very
little effect on the overall calories
spent. It'd be very hard to measure that
and be sure, so I don't know, but I
suspect not.
- Any comments about the microbiome, the
intestinal microbiome and energy
metabolism?
- Yeah, so there's lots of great work now
looking at other factors that affect
energy expenditure and obesity for that
matter and the microbiome, this sort of
rainforest that we carry around in our
guts has been a topic, a really hot topic
recently. Two things: First, none of this
stuff on energetics means that you don't
have to exercise. So people often say
like, "Well, this means I don't have to
exercise." Nope, what this means it that
exercise is going to do different things
to your body than were kind of maybe
taught. It's not gonna ramp up your
calorie expenditure every day necessarily,
because your body's going to adapt if you
start exercising than doing something
differently. Your body's going to adapt to
that metabolically. But that adaptation
itself might be really good for your
health, and in any case, there's all sorts
of non-metabolic things that exercise does
that keeps us healthy, so you still have
to exercise. You still have to exercise.
You still have to exercise. Okay,
microbiomes. We don't know enough yet
about the function of the microbiome in
terms of its effect on our overall
metabolism. We know that people who are
fat or thin tend to have different
microbiomes. Mice who are fat or thin can
have different microbiomes, you can make
them fat or thin by giving them different
microbiomes. So really interesting stuff
and it has to do with metabolism for sure.
Exactly how all those things link
together, we don't know yet.
- Thanks a lot. I believe we've completed
the question period, so time for remarks.
- [Ajit] I'd like to take the opportunity
to thank those who made the symposium
possible. To the symposium chairs,
speakers, the supporters and the audience
for attending and your great questions,
give yourself a round of applause. The
mark of a great CARTA symposium is that it
raises more questions than answers and I
think we really did that today. And as
Steve pointed out, it's really a mystery,
and in fact all of exploring anthropogony
is like solving a murder mystery. So I'd
like to leave you with the words of the
great detective. "When you have eliminated
the impossible, whatever remains, however
improbable, must be the truth." Thank you
all very much for coming.
♪ [music] ♪